[Music]
lorraine here speaking with vfx
supervisor of marvel studios one
division tara demarco hey tara hi
lorraine it's so great to get to talk to
you i'm so thrilled to talk about this
show because it is such a love letter to
classic television yeah kevin feige
really wanted us at every turn to stay
as authentic to period filmmaking as we
could was there anything that you found
really surprising about working in black
and white the most surprising thing
about working in black and white is then
looking at the color because you'll see
some crazy colors that were done with
our production design and our costume
department because they all knew they
would film better so
red films quite dark on the sensor it
just goes super super dark and
unreadable we were losing visions
features so we did two days of makeup
palette testing where we tried all
different shades of blue and different
shades of sheen because some of that
performance we keep like some of that
face is is the real face and we augment
it with cg clearly but paul as an actor
is so expressive and particularly when
he was channeling his sick himself he
was so expressive and we didn't want to
lose any of that early on in the season
we get to see wanda in her 1950s
paradise she is having a lot of magical
fun in the kitchen
where did you decide what's going to be
practical and what's going to be vfx we
would all sit around a table and and
decide as a group we would decide with
props and special effects and production
design and talk about the dimensions of
the set and what we wanted the effect to
be and what we wanted
wanted to see or feel do we need the
actors to be able to see that thing
practically moving through space or did
it just appear so we would all discuss
the parameters
and then we would dive in and figure out
like okay well
this one thing would be great on wires
because there's no way you're going to
be able to cheat the effect of a
puppeteer like bobbling an item through
space like that's a surprisingly hard
thing to do in cg is recreate the hand
of an old school puppeteer working on
wires it's pretty wild to see the
footage from behind the scenes because
you don't realize how close the
puppeteers are what were some of the
ways that items were puppeteered all of
them so we
we puppeteered things from the ceiling
we
did them from the floor we
tried all of the ways so really it was
about looking okay what what's the best
way to get the effect we want and then
how do you rig that it's like oh will
you put a wire from one side of the
living room through the set window and
then have someone pull it across so once
you have all of this wonderful
puppeteering
uh put together with the actors in their
scene
how do you take that into vfx and make
it all one seamless product we take all
of our in-camera elements all of the
pieces with puppeteered wires still in
them and then get to work at removing
all of those wires and rods and
everything else and then
we take that scene as prepped and go to
cg
with our director and he might say can i
have a rolling pin or can you make me
one more of those cookie jars and then
we'll begin modeling those items with
colors that are cg friendly for black
and white and we'll lay them out in the
scene do animation that
is janky enough that it could have been
done by a human with a rod or a wire we
didn't want anything too smooth because
then we would give up the gag with
everything that was done with pliers
[Music]
i especially love the moment where wanda
finds out that she's pregnant and the
whole room goes from black and white
into this bloom of color where did you
start with this process when you knew
you had to take the world into color we
were really encouraged by the studio to
look at film effects that could have
happened in the era
and so
the 60s the film effects that could
happen in the era were all about optical
printing and how you could expose
different bits of film and then
re-expose them together in an optical
printer
and we took inspiration from that and
thought
what if you separated out the color
channels
and really warped them to be separate
from one another and then were able to
re-expose them and layer them
and that's the effect that creates the
color bloom and so we ended up with an
effect that would have been tricky to do
in the 60s but at least was true to the
principles and then our little stars
that are animated around were a nod to
animating on the film from that era
[Music]
so when wanda and vision are getting
into nesting mode setting up the nursery
there's some really charming moments
that happen
as you know things start to literally
take shape what were some of the ways
that that was shot to trick the eye the
crib coming together was filmed with
wires with puppeteers
the paint brushes we did both ways there
were some puppeteered paintbrushes that
i think ultimately we used for reference
and we did cg paint brushes in that
scene there's also some wonderful
moments my favorite being the butterfly
mobile what was the initial idea for how
much of that you could really do
practically as butterflies i don't
imagine are super cooperative
butterflies are not super cooperative
but one of the butterflies on paul's
nose is real and the others are all cg
so we wanted at least one so that we
could see how it moved and see what it
looked like and see that contact and
actually just the wonder in their faces
when we had this real live butterfly
attached to paul's nose pretty
incredible and then
what we decided to do was animate the
butterflies and and that allowed us that
opened us up to make it more fantastical
because if we had had real butterflies
you know they have phenomenal colors but
they might not exactly match our nursery
mobile and this allowed us to art direct
them a little closer to the mobile and
get that perfect transition moment
[Music]
so we have the epic moment where vision
meets vision how do you
make them look
like they're both vision while giving
them their own distinct look the new
vision was designed by marvel's very own
biz dev team he has an identical body
but a slightly different costume he has
an identical head but slightly different
panel shapes and we gave him an
interesting new synthesiod eye things
that are important differences the new
vision doesn't have a mind stone
so we put
something mind stone-esque in
the area where the mind stone was
so the interesting thing that comes with
filming this kind of scene you have two
visions you have one paul bettany
how do you then uh
shoot that scene to put it together in
post we shoot the scene twice so we shot
every scene with
paul
as the hero and then he would act
opposite one of his stunt doubles so
that every performance is paul so once
you have two paws and you've got him
into one shot uh how do you then create
a logic battle we take all of the
elements from the set we'll cut them all
out and assemble them into scenes so
that we feel like it's all one scene and
then we figure out what additional
enhancements need to happen so that they
really sit together does it mean a
little bit of set extension or some
atmosphere or tracking one vision into
the other's original photography so that
they share a camera move whatever we
need to do to make them both feel like
they're really there and they're in a
library how how was that shot was that a
library did you create one we scouted a
library that ultimately we decided we
couldn't shoot there because we needed
to hang them quite high and this little
library didn't really want us to destroy
their space so we
found it loved it photographed it and
then we went back to our stage and built
three quarters of it for real so that we
could practically hang and spin them on
the second floor so that we could get
the shots from down below of them
talking and spinning and so we could get
some shots drifting with them as they're
on the second floor
ultimately we ended up rebuilding a
bunch of that library in cg including
the dome and the skylight just so we
would have full control but it was
massively helpful to have a real set and
a lot of that set lives in the final
film are there any layers or
different things that you put on top to
raise the stakes of that feeling
absolutely we
put
bits of paper and laser beams we have
exploding wood and we cut through the
floor so you end up with lots of stuff
in the air and some stuff coming towards
lens that helps the viewer feel like
they're really in the middle of this
tense battle beat looking back at this
process working on this entire series
the first disney plus series for the mcu
uh what has been sort of your favorite
component or part of getting to work on
this process i think my favorite part of
working on this process
has been working with the director in
the studio in the new character
development every time someone else is
introduced
i'm like oh who is that and how cool is
it and now we've been able to contribute
to that thank you so much tara it was so
wonderful talking to you everyone be
sure to watch marvel studios one
division now streaming all episodes on
disney plus
[Music]